teenagers are notorious for causing
upheaval
as they stake their ground in social
webs
turns out the young of the most massive
carnivorous dinosaurs
carved out a vast space for their entire
species
in prehistoric ecosystems
paleontologists have
unearthed dinosaur fossils that cover an
array of species
of different sizes on a global scale
medium-sized carnivore fossils are
slightly less common than small and
large
within narrower geographical regions the
disparity is amplified
this gap has been a mystery to
scientists
did those carnivore fossils fail to
survive until modern day
or had they simply not planted their
trowels in the right plot of soil
a new study suggests another answer that
carnivorous dinos weighing between
10 and 1 000 kilograms were replaced by
young mega theropods
hulking carnivores like t-rex that
weighed over 1 000 kilos fully grown
as they developed from football-sized
eggs into more substantial juveniles
before eventually filling the shoes of
their colossal parents
the researchers examined 557 dinosaur
taxa
spanning seven continents and 136
million years
across the jurassic and cretaceous
carnivores weighing between
100 to 300 kilos were far less common in
local habitats
than small and large species it's as if
a mammal community
in the modern african savannah had no
carnivores
between the size of a lion and a
bat-eared box
the study differed from most dinosaur
research because it looked at ancient
ecosystems
which are tricky to describe and confirm
through fossil evidence
so the researchers crafted mathematical
models based on biomass
to make predictions about juveniles of
particular species
the models indicated that an enclave of
little giants
likely excluded a more diverse range of
species similar in size
this dynamic can be found in modern
ecosystems
when animals have young whose bodies are
extremely small compared to fully grown
adults
such as egg-laying reptiles like komodo
dragons and large crocodiles
they can dominate wide swaths of
ecosystems as they progress through life
shouldering out species that might have
otherwise filled those roles
the findings bolster efforts to
understand how dinosaurs functioned in
their habitats
new ways of studying microscopic scrapes
on animal teeth
could be applied to dinosaur fossils
that would help quantify how dinosaurs
hunted
rather than typical skull analysis of
how they ate to fill additional gaps in
knowledge
yet another trailblaze as we journey to
conceive of a land before time